don't give them permission to do so by
Council staff please note that the
meeting will be audio recorded
please switch off Mobile's phones or
turn them to silent
so everyone checks
please note the toilet and hand washing
facilities are in the foyer area
members of the public are reminded that
this is an official council meeting and
the item before us will be debated
according to the usual Council rules for
the council meetings to which the public
are omitted
members of the public are not permitted
to speak at this meeting unless they
have previously registered to speak
pleasure to speak with the Democratic
services
in this way everyone present will be
able to hear the debate and counselors
will be able to make an informed
decision can I please also remind you to
be respectful of all the attending
meetings including other members of the
public counselors and officers
members of the public while we are you
are of course interact with a foil or
take for photography and photographs
during this meeting can I please
emphasize to you that this should be
done without disruption to the meeting
and can only be done from a designated
area in the public seating
can I please therefore ask you to raise
your hand clearly in the air if you wish
to take photographs or filming this
evening
your weight
and she's in the front so that's not the
problem
a minute ago
that's fast
it's a long time now
apology
this members it's now 7 30.
members there is a need to use
microphones during the meeting when I
invite you to speak please wait until
there is a microphone in front of you
you before you sorry let's start again
please wait until there's a microphone
in front of you before you speaking as
microphones are needed for the hearing
Loop and for the audio recording now if
any one of the members can't hear
um anyone can you please indicate
these are all switched on and ready for
you to speak and will be unmuted by
offices for you
please make sure that the microphone
microphone is directly in front of your
mouth before speaking
members voting will be done on a show of
hands in line with the Constitution I
will ask for a show of hands four and
then against recommendations will also
ask for a show of hands for those
wishing to abstain from voting
I would move from the chair that I want
to move
an item seven points
item seven to be item three or if I can
I have that as a second of course thank
you do members agree please so we move
that forward that's that's seven then
was
it's London Road London Road
yeah they move it up
up to number three
yeah please
so all the original ones will be
um
just getting the agenda up to see where
this is
so you're you're moving that to
so that will be heard after which item
after six
months it will be heard after 66 I'll be
right that's hold on yeah
C6 very low because they were uh a joke
we couldn't get them through the last
meeting so they've got to come first and
the next one will be London Road is that
is are all members agreed
thank you
agenda items one or two apologies for
absence uh with a one apology for Leslie
Butcher and I'm Council Eileen Gadson is
substitute have we got any other ones
please
so you could
not we've got councilor Stanley and
councilor Knight and councilor James
Newport
will be uh standing up for councilor
Stanley and councilor Hawaii will be
substituting for councilor Knights
okay
non-members attending we have councilor
sperrying Council Arrow councilor
Woodson Council McPherson
oh sorry cancel Daniel Felton sorry
I've done share a word and councilor
Wilson thank you
members minutes of the meeting held on
24th of January 2023 are these agreed
members
thank you and I can sign them yes thank
you
agenda 5 to receive Declarations of
Interest I will start I've got a
non-procuniary interest because I'm a
member of the conservative Club in
London Road
uh counselor
constable
I'm also a member of the conservative
Club in London Road so it's a number
cunery non-punery
councilor Gustin
I can't hit can we can you hear me I
also have a non-portunity interest
ing
I also have a non-pecuniary interest in
the conservative Club application thank
you councilor Mill
I also have a non-pecuniary interest as
a member of the conservative Club thank
you how's the Mason Mrs Mason
thank you um
I'm going to be different I haven't got
an interest in the conservative Club
however I oops I have what could be
perceived as having an indirect interest
in item
well 22 to 24 South End Road Hockley and
in the interest of transparency I will
leave after speaking so that I'm not
influencing the debate thank you thank
you very much
anyone else has only got any interests
no thank you very much members
I've already moved the motion rule 9
city
um so I've had a seconder and we've done
voting on that and everyone's agreed
thank you
let's move the agenda around a bit I'm
sorry
a giant agenda item six
is 22 Strokes zero triple one four full
31 bowling Road Great White Ring Katie
Fowler will present the officers report
over to you Katie please thank you
chairman
uh so the application site is located on
the south side of Barling Road and is
commonly occupied by a non-lawful
dwelling so on the screen we can see the
aerial photograph and this is the site
with the unlawful dwelling in question
the site is within the Metropolitan
Greenbelt but due to the site's previous
sighting within a rural settlement the
dwellings along Barling Road are far
larger than is expected for a typical
Greenbelt area
so on this second photo we can just see
the application site with the undo for
dwelling at present
and on this third photo we have an
aerial shot before the building was
demolished and rebuilt and so this was
the dwelling that stood previously
although members would have seen the
previous dwelling in plan form the
photos on screen should help members to
picture the dwelling that was demolished
and the previous appearance of the site
so I'll just go through these and so
this is the rear elevation
and then we have a kind of bird side
view of that
the rebuild of this dwelling was granted
in 2020 members may be familiar with the
site due to an identical application
appearing on a weekly list prior to
Christmas the application was referred
to committee however due to an
Administration area era a decision was
incorrectly issued
to provide some further context the
dwelling that stands on the site was
refused planning permission in 2021
whilst planning permission was granted
for the rebuild of the dwelling
identical to that which was demolished
it was this proposal that was refused
which was built out a subsequent appeal
decision was lodged and this appeal was
dismissed in early 2022 requiring the
dwelling to be altered back to the
dwelling which had been demolished on
site the application subject to this
committee therefore must be considered
in light of disappear decision and the
demolished dwelling which benefits from
planet mission to be rebuilt like for
like and just to provide I appreciate
it's quite confusing with the amount of
different applications we've had on this
site so
um the pictures that are on screen now
the blue measurements are those taken
from the plan of the refused application
and the yellow taken from what's on site
because they do differ slightly so in my
report you'll see on the table there's
measurements of the demolished the
on-site the refused and that proposed
just because there are differentiations
between them all so
um of particular I just take us to this
plan here you can see that the kind of
hatching on the top right here was not
included on the plans but was built out
to be habitable space
um and then
you can see from here from this plan
that it is slightly larger on uh on site
so now what is proposed is the
alteration of the on-site dwelling to
create a dwelling that is reflective in
mass and scale of the demolished and
approved dwelling the red line on the
plan depicts the outline of the
demolished dwellings so you it probably
is a bit faint here but you can see the
chimney in particular so that's not a
chimney that exists that is the outline
of the previous dwelling and then it
goes up here and then along slightly
um so to achieve this the proposed
dwelling has been reduced in height and
the single story extensions removed
consideration must therefore be had as
to whether these alterations would
result in a dwelling that would have a
comparable impact to the demolished
dwelling upon the green belt
paragraph 149d of the mppf considers
proposals for replacement buildings
which are in the same use and not
materially larger than the one it
replaces to be appropriate development
within the green belt policy dm21
similarly permits the construction of
replacement dwellings where the
replacement would not be over 25 larger
in floor space than the original
building
case law has established that to
consider whether something is materially
larger this could be looked at in terms
of floor space or built volume but
ultimately it should be of a similar
scale looking firstly at floor space we
have to primarily consider the original
dwelling the officer report sets out
that the proposed wedding would be
greater than 25 of the original
footprint
however this is also the case for the
demolished dwelling but which was
granted kind of permission for a light
for like replacement in 2020 and so the
plans on the screen the right hand ones
depict the floor space of the dwelling
which was demolished and granted plan of
permission in 2020 and then the
left-hand ones are now what is proposed
therefore the proposed dwelling can be
considered against National policy which
requires the replacement dwelling to not
be materially larger than the building
in which it replaces so in this case
this left-hand building would be
replacing this right hand building
I would draw attention to table the
table and Pi page 9.9 of the officer's
report just give you a sec to go to that
page 9.9 oh this might be the rip the
previous one 6.9 sorry
so this table
depicts the demolished slash approved
dwelling the refused the on-site and the
proposed and then sets out the floor
space across the ground floor first
floor second floor and then the total
floor space of those
so the table demonstrates that floor
space the floor space of the proposed
dwelling is comparable to that of the
demolished across the ground floor and
first floor
although the second four floor for floor
space of the demolished dwelling is not
entirely known the pictures shown
earlier demonstrate an extensive roof
space that would have certainly been
able to accommodate some of the
accommodation it is therefore considered
that a floor space of some sort would
have been out to have been accommodated
within the second floor
of importance is also the appeal
decision on site the inspector was clear
in his decision that the second floor
accommodation of the dwelling on site
does add to the dwelling being
materially larger than the one it
replaces however looking at the bottom
row of the table it shows that across
two and a half Stories the floor space
can be seen cumulatively in Greater
comparison to that of the demolished
dwelling than that of the dwelling
subject to the appeal
whilst floor space is the first test
case or has established that the impact
of a building may still be significant
depending on the massing and bulk of the
replacement building
I'd now draw your attention members to
the table which I guess will be on 6.14
rather than 9.14
so the table again depicts the
differencing between the approved
demolished refused on-site unproposed
and then the different heights and
widths and depths of the application so
the plans on screen
um hopefully the colors are clear I've
tried to make them a little bit clearer
but
um the blue shade is the
dwelling which was demolished and then
you should be able to see just a tinge
of orange or red color behind which
um is the proposed wedding so if I just
go through these it should become a
little bit clearer when they're slightly
different so here again you can see the
blue color which comes up here and then
out and then the orange so just to
reiterate the blue is the demolished and
approved dwelling and then the orange
red color is the proposed wedding
it is evidence from the plans and screen
and the table that the proposed wedding
would be comparable to that which was
demolished although the proposed
dwelling would have a greater volume in
some respects it would have less of a
sprawl than the demolished dwelling the
additional bulk and mass into the roof
is considered to result in a greater
condensed dwelling and smaller footprint
than that of the demolished Welling
which would had a greater spool
although the bulk and mass of the roof
would have a greater impact than the
demolished dwelling this would be offset
by the Lesser impact of the ground floor
and sprawl of the demolished dwelling
um and the last one I'll turn you to in
the office report is on page 6.15
paragraph 3.35 towards the bottom of the
of the page
so members will see an extract from the
inspector's decision relating to the
dwelling on site the issue that the
inspector takes with the dwelling on
site is that the additional story
results in the building being taller and
materially larger as a result of
accommodating this whilst the proposed
dwelling would utilize the love space
the ridge height has been significantly
reduced overall where the bulk and mass
of the dwelling would be great in some
respects to that of the demolished
dwelling it would be offset by having
less of an impact in other respects
whereas in comparison the on-site
dwelling is materially larger in all
aspects it is considered that the
proposed wedding would successfully
overcome the objection objections which
had been raised by the inspector within
the appeal decision
and just to go through the images on on
the screen the red running is the
proposed wedding and the blue in the
background here is the dwelling that's
on site and which was refused previously
so and just to show the ground floors to
see the exact the extensions which have
been removed the blue have been removed
and the orangey ready color is what's
proposed
um
in terms of the other material
considerations it has been assessed that
the scale of the proposed dwelling would
sit comfortably within the application
site and the surrounding area it's not
considered that the proposed dwelling
would dominate or overbear the street
sync given its reduced height
the dwelling would also not be
considered to impact upon neighboring
dwellings in this regard for the most
part the proposed fenestration would not
Overlook neighboring dwellings with the
exception of the first floor flank
window however as this window would
serve an ensuite it would be reasonable
to require this window to be obscure
glazed and non-opening the development
would be compliant with the policy
requirements of garden size refuse and
waste storage technical housing
standards parking and trees
members may recall uh that the addendum
of the previous committee recommended an
additional condition which restricted
the residential Garden to only the area
hatched and restricted the erection of
permitted development built outbuildings
the addendum also amended condition two
to include a revised site plan that
showed a complete depiction of the land
owned by the applicant
so these conditions were worded as
follows they are on screen but I
appreciate they might be a bit hard to
read so I'll just read them out briefly
so condition two would be amended to say
the development hereby permitted should
be carried out in complete accordance
with the following approved plans it
lists all the plans and then just amends
the location plan
which is 100 a instead of 100 the second
condition which is the additional
condition is worded to say the area
shown hatched on drawing number 100a
shall be the only area used as
residential Garden at any time note
we're standing the provisions of article
3 schedule 2 part 1 Class E of the Town
and Country planning General permitted
development order 2015 including any
order revoking or reenacting that order
with or without modification no
outbuilding shall be erected or
otherwise provided on any part of the
site either shown hatched or the area
beyond that and just to show this plan
so the red is the application site just
go through that here
and then the blue is the site owned by
the applicant and I've just hatched this
bit here so that only this part of the
site will be used as residential Garden
but there there would be no permitted
development outbuildings on any part of
the site
this is due to the applicant owning the
land to the South and the potential harm
to the Greenbelt that would result were
our opinions erected on this area
hatched or outlined in blue to the South
the application is recommended for
approval chairman subject to the
conditions set out in the officer report
and addendum to the previous committee
thank you thank you very much
we have a counselor Mrs McPherson
you have five minutes uh councilman
first and I'll let you know when you're
done four okay thank you
thank you chairman um hopefully as
chairman and having had issues in your
own Ward you will use your discretion on
the five minute rule if that's possible
please
um members I will not have time to read
through each point
I quote so please have your pens ready
to take note when I quote pages and
reference numbers
31 Barling Road was previously known as
Orchard House you'll understand why
shortly built in the late 1940s plans
only date from 1967 in show in 1967
extension to the dining room two
bathrooms cloaked room a new staircase
added in
1984 Conservatory added to the rear in
1986 a two-story side extension was
added all these were approved through
the proper process followed planning law
please members know how the original
footprint had already been extended
several applications have come forward
since 2017 all refused up to 2020
now taking you forward to 2020 in April
2020 during lockdown I was alerted by
residents The Orchard House had been
demolished not only demolished all the
trees and Greenery also taken
so not only were my residents trapped in
their houses following lockdown rules
but had to enjoy living opposite a
construction site as an illegal
construction site there were no
operating hours no conditions they
worked weekends and bank holidays
including New Year's Day
officers were alerted at that time that
the house had been demolished and works
were being commenced on first of
February I was asked by residents was
there any news I had presumed following
um
alerting officers and enforcement notice
had already been served but let us know
I followed this up again with officers
on the 8th of March 2021 and was told an
enforcement notice was yet to be served
in relation to the work carried out I
have here the email yet
um page 6.3 2.5 clearly says an
enforcement notice was served in June
2021 this is more than a year from when
our enforcement team were originally
notified that the building was being
demolished could you pop the slides up
now please Katie thank you
so in here you've got three pictures
um the top picture shows the building
as it was the picture to the right when
it was being demolished in 2020 and
Below to the left is the picture now I
know Katie said slightly larger but
please look for yourself for example
there were no rooms in the original
building in the roof
page 6.3 2.2 can I draw your attention
to that members and also on the same
page 2.3
which pop-up slide two please Katie
thanks
here you have some before and after
photos
now I disagree wholeheartedly with uh
officers comments when they say the bulk
and mess is clearly the same it is not
the new build is substantially larger
you also now know why it was called
Orchard House
I can't see a tree there at all and when
we have residents supporting
one tree staying in a road and yeah a
whole Orchard is demolished without
planning permission it does perhaps make
a lot of people feel heartbroken to see
that
his photos side by side ask yourself the
impact on the green belt
people say in your papers it isn't
substantial
for further information 31 Barling Road
previously known as Orchard House
it had a historic Orchard let alone the
impact on the wildlife that were
demolished along the side of the house
it's really quite heartbreaking next
slide please Katie
now again we were told that all the
houses there are large
the existing Street Scene is in front of
you it's made up of a ribbon of large
detached Wellings with substantial
Curtis leech that's page 6.4 3.2 members
I can see the building there smack in
the middle it sticks out like a sore
thumb
but then that's down to you members to
decide if you think that that is in
keeping with the rest of the street
scene or not
on four minutes okay thank you next
slide please Katie
now this side slide shows both sides of
the road
unfortunately you can't zoom in to show
it but opposite are mainly semi-detached
Bungalows and again there you go right
in the middle with that semicircle in
the front with no trees is uh 31 Barling
Road
materially larger is key with this
application members all I can ask
committee members is for you to please
go through this application with a
fine-tooth comb
it appears a done deal even though we
went to reinforcement M1
and make any recommendations to stop
further developments bearing in mind the
history the blatant disregard for
planning not to mention the impact this
has had on the environment thank you
members
thank you councilman person Council
councilor FD you're the other
counselor for the wall do you need would
you wish to say anything
my members I'm open is any other what
obviously World counselors do they wish
to speak on this please
no indication right members I'll take it
to the committee has anyone got any
observations uh they would like to speak
to council Ahoy
thank you chairman
um
I've been looking at this one's
interesting can you speak to them please
sorry try to reverberate in my ears
um
I agree with councilor McPherson I I've
looked at this planning application I've
looked at the inspectors report which
I've got in front of me and
the
what is proposed is very different to
what was knocked down and also what is
proposing this application is different
or it hasn't really taken into account
what the inspector said as far as I'm
concerned it still is materially
larger
I think the report is trying to include
floor space which shouldn't be which the
inspector did not include
there is no second floor on the original
property and I don't think we should
count that the inspector certainly
didn't
um
and on on that basis it is the building
is material larger when you look at the
street scene has been shown by the
pictures it's not comparable to the rest
of the straight it's it is very
different and I think ultimately which
is also
a great body inspector it wasn't um
wasn't appropriate it was not
appropriate development for the green
belt
um
I'm not sure if anyone else is going to
speak on this subject but I'm proposing
that we refuse the application on the
three three grounds I've just stated
which I will repeat which are
inappropriate development in the green
belt
um it
it is not in keeping with the street
scene
and the the
this building is we're looking at on
these plans here is still material a lot
materially larger than the original
build
[Music]
yes that's
what I said I thought yeah but I'll have
you a second or please I have no idea
no you haven't rebuild that's right has
any other mem
sorry
thank you Casey just have a couple
clarifications please
is there a planning what's the planning
for 2020 on there
as in what was passed what was passed
so is it what we're looking at now is
that substantially bigger than what was
passed in 2020
so if I just come to these this
comparison again
um I think it's worth clarifying that
the aerial photographs at the moment
obviously show what's on site and that
isn't what's proposed here and they do
differ
um so the blue line if I oh I've lost
the thing here we go
um
the blue building is what was existing
on the site
and then the orange outline is what's
proposed now so obviously from the front
it's
not too dissimilar and then if I go to
the side elevation is where you can see
the differences so you can see that
obviously at some point the Orange is
greater than the blue but then at other
points the blue is greater than the
orange so it's officer's opinion that
although in some places there may be a
greater volume of floor space there is
actually less floor space in others and
cumulatively that impact is balanced out
and also with the 2020
not eyesight
um
application there's no
conditions whereas this one's got
conditions on it
yeah so this one would have stricter
control and the 2020
application is in force now so if we
didn't do this they'd still build the
2020 application
which is different from what is there
now and this also this application is
smaller than what is there now just for
clarification is that correct that's
correct yes thank you
yes thank you thank you chairman
um
try that that's better thank you
ah the train of thoughts gone
um this does look to me very much like
over development um
I wouldn't go along with an absolute
refusal but um I would like to propose
perhaps that this matter be deferred and
a site visit be arranged so that we
could have a look at this uh at some
stage please
I don't know if I have a second for that
so we've got another motion on that you
want to defer this I would like to do
further this at the moment and have a
a site visit for members to look at this
in detail
against members
someone's got a phone going that's a
fine for you for the charity box
and any obsessions
that has been carried
so it's been Carriage members for a
deferment
seven and a site visit so officers could
arrange site visit please
um against four of same month thank you
members
members will go on to
item
can I just make a request
I've got every sympathy with the world
councilor's opinion but what I would
like to know is a couple of questions
that I haven't had the opportunity to
ask and I'd like them to be covered
I'd like them to be covered in the
report when it comes back to the
committee yeah we can't do that now
because we've gone that we voted it yes
I know it's being deferred I'm asking
for these two points to be covered
them yeah okay I will do that will be
fine thank you thank you
iTunes referred from the weekly list
this item could not be heard at the last
meeting so it's 66 Ferry Road holbridge
22 stroke zero zero nine two eight full
okay so as everyone's got
you
want to be used I will I'm just trying
to find out who's going to speak on this
actually
thank you like can you
speak please thank you chairman this
application is on the Eastern side of
Ferry Road just for the city Junction
with Abbey Road
the site is part of a small group of
dwellings you'll see that are unusually
or in the context of this street set
back further than we usually see there
are small group as I say with large
front Gardens
um if we could see the photographs
briefly please and just scroll gently
through those uh to there we see the
outbuilding at the back of the site
which is used as a a gymnasium and
fitness Suite but it's also got a single
cutting chair if you like hairdressers
Salon in it that was approved in
September 2017 by the council
and uh the the business was at that time
the application operating from the
applicant's hallway and kitchen of his
house and he made an application to
transfer that activity that was in the
dwelling to this outbuilding that he had
and uh the council granted it there were
a number of conditions because obviously
there's a there's a problem that we're
no doubt going to come on to about where
you get commercial uses in Residential
Properties and there's there's extremes
you get people quietly working on a
drawing board perhaps or doing
accountancy on a laptop or something and
you wouldn't know they were there and
you get the other extreme of like car
repairs and noisy activities paint
spraying Etc well uses like this are
somewhere in the middle and it's for the
council to judge whether they're
acceptable in a residential area or if
they're not and a device to help that
acceptance is the use of planning
conditions now there's two that are
issue tonight one that is set out at
page sorry paragraph 19 on page 715 of
your report is that the decision in
September 17 was personal to the
applicant so it could only be for that
applicant as long as he was residing at
that address and then condition four
which was a limit on the hours
there were separate conditions that
prevented use on Saturday Sundays bank
and public holidays and a fifth
condition that allowed for only one
workstation with the applicant oh sorry
before I get to that in the previous
application the applicant advised that
there would be only one member of Staff
basically himself with appointments
between nine and six two days a week and
between 12 midday and 8 PM one day a
week with the occasional Saturday
working that's what he applied for and
from what I've just said you've probably
gleaned that's not the shape of the
consent that he got we limited him in
hours till Monday to Friday between nine
and six
so the applicant has advised that he
also at that time attended appointments
in people's homes or elsewhere so it's a
mix at that time of working at home and
uh and off-site
Council gave him a consent so he's able
to work from home Monday to Friday
if you wished gave him that scope okay
so the conditions are contrary to those
that were put forward back in 17 that's
Now history
but the council felt that in granting a
consent those conditions were necessary
to address policy dm33 that you have
which is a criteria-based assessment
when these applications come up from
time to time and part three of that was
to safeguard the amenity of adjoining
occupiers so we didn't end up with a
commercial use that would be ill-fitting
or disruptive to the residential
adjoining homes
and in this case the noise and activity
such as it is is to do with customers
and maybe staff or whatever Comins and
goings at the end of appointments there
isn't any known Machinery or anything
like we get with other uses that causes
decibels or anything like that it's the
general mitigation through conditions of
the activity associated with the coming
going and of the use proposed basically
to make it fit with the tolerances of
the residential environment
so the council previously found against
the late evening opening
and if we jump to plan three please this
approved at that time the layout of the
unit and you'll see it's predominantly
down to the applicants
um gymnasium and domestic use the small
Corner that we see
see here is that given over to the
single station for the hairdressing
activity
now what you've got sorry before you
tonight is uh the applicant has come
back to us now seeking to vary the
personal condition condition two that's
one of the two conditions he's seeking
to vary
this would allow as hopefully clear from
the report to allow for a training of a
work experienced student who has anxiety
but would specifically benefit from
shadowing alongside the applicant rather
than be constrained or disadvantaged
perhaps in a larger busier salon so it's
rather tailored to to her needs it would
be very suitable for that and the
applicant stresses that the student
would not be cutting or styling but
would be observing and supporting in a
way of clearing up making Refreshments
doing some hair washes perhaps activity
like that that would allow her to Shadow
the main stylist and learn learn that
skill
the applicant stresses that there
wouldn't be any increase in clients or
activity to what's already permitted
the second part of the application is to
change the hours of business you'll see
from the report that the applicant's
circumstances have slightly changed
these now have a young family and
needing to balance his work around the
parenting needs things like doing school
runs and you'll see from the
representations from people who have
written in that they also find that the
late hours proposed up until 8 PM
um I think I've lost myself now I think
it's two nights a week yes Tuesdays and
Thursday evenings until 8 PM that suits
their lifestyle as well
now in analysis
um there is always difficulty as I think
I'm making clear in trying to balance
commercial uses alongside residential
and inevitably there's a form of
compromise
the broadly National policy encourages
small businesses to grow from the home
environment so that as they develop they
get a clientele
reputation their business grows they
outgrow the home and need premises and
from that they create jobs and that's
hopefully a success story
[Music]
um
the difficulty though as I said is
accommodating such a use in a
residential setting
we have an objection from the
immediately adjoining uh occupier but
you'll see from the agenda there are
other letters of support as I've
explained uh supporting the use and the
flexibility proposed therefore it's it's
for this committee to come to a view as
to the acceptance of that now officers
you'll see are recommending refusal
because we're concerned of the the
framing of this difficulty with the
existing conditions
we've previously uh rejected the late
hour opening that was initially
suggested back in 2017 to be one night
per week but is now proposed to be two
and also
um
we can envisage that the taking on of a
of a supporting
um sort of trainee
um that can inevitably lead to perhaps
some support for the main stylist in in
covering work we probably are well aware
of uh trainees we've uh taken with
ourselves when you they start they they
don't know much so they can do very
little but over the course of their time
with you they get better skills and
therefore where would that lead so we
we're concerned about that and therefore
um despite the letters of support and
that you see before you
offices are recommending refusal for the
reason that's set out in the report now
if members agree that recommendation the
applicant would still be able to
continue under the consent that he has
so we're not refusing or recommending
new refuse if you can't do anything
we're saying that we're recommending to
you that you refuse the proposed changes
to the uh constraints that he would work
under the net effect of a refusal is
that he would continue under the consent
that he has hopefully that's clear
chairman
thank you very much we have one speaker
public speaker and I will apologize if I
say your name wrong Mr mug
yachty
sorry uh we go tonight you've got five
minutes and again I'll let you know when
you've done four minutes okay thank you
thank you chairman and good evening
everyone after reading the planning
officer's report I contacted Talent at
RDC
she suggested that a condition can be
put in place
councilor Adrian Eves kindly suggested
to limit any workers in addition to
business owner to a recognized trainee
only now and in the future
a recognized trainee would mean an
unqualified person who is currently
studying towards an mvq level one or
level two in hairdressing
this will keep the business use low-key
and incidental to enjoyment of the
dwelling house
unfortunately my neighbors at 68 and
myself got off on the wrong foot from
the first day I moved into my home I can
honestly say I have done my best to be
kind and respectful to them but it's
just not good enough
as regards to the two additional hours
till 8 pm on a Tuesday and Thursday Mr
Kilburn stipulates that this may disrupt
the quiet time that might be reasonably
reasonably expected
noise from clients Vehicles firstly
Ferry Road is the busiest Road in
holbridge with two parades of shops just
20 yards up the road and buses that go
up and down till midnight that actually
rattle our houses
unfortunately if it's not clients
visiting me it's me driving out in my
car which in my opinion is a lot more
disruptive especially in winter months
when my diesel car could be set on the
drive warming up defrosting Windows
whilst I'm gathering tools products and
equipment in the salon due to the nature
of what in the salon due to the nature
of working from people's homes hair
Services take a while longer resulting
with me arriving home close to midnight
which is an example of an event that
occurred just last week for a client who
lives just around the corner
just some food for thought for members
of the board would this be any different
to a friend visiting my house once or
twice a week what if I had friends
visiting my home and or outbuilding
every evening for social gatherings I
strongly believe that any social
Gatherings would be far more disruptive
than a client and myself sitting in the
salon having a chat and a coffee whilst
I do their hair
in paragraph 25 Mr Kilburn refers to
noisy equipment
my loudest tour in the salon is a Dyson
hairdryer runs at a maximum of 70 74
decibels which is as loud as your
dishwasher at home
my neighbors at 68 Ferry Road are
actually 40 meters away from the salon
so impossible to hear anything I've
tested the Dyson hair dryer and left it
running on full power I went outside and
closed the door and could not hear a
thing even with the doors open the sound
of the hairdryer couldn't be heard from
my lawn area
out respect for all my neighboring
properties I'm happy to make sure all
windows and doors are closed during
extended business hours only
during the summer months the salon is
equipped with air cons so will not be an
issue
what I can't promise is peace and quiet
from my two and four-year-olds that will
be splashing in paddling pools and
bouncing like maniacs on a bouncy castle
as you can see from the report many
local neighbors have stated positive and
valid comments so please take a moment
to have a look
I feel a little disappointed that I
respected my planning conditions
extremely carefully despite being
accused of All Sorts from my neighbors
at 68 Ferry Road who did not even
educate themselves to any of the
conditions but still made inaccurate
false claims on numerous occasions
against me I am solely responsible for
the Cummins and going of all clients at
my salon
I believe that I've never had a genuine
complaint I feel like the planners at
RDC need to understand the respect and
appreciation I have for them and that I
would never do anything to jeopardize my
current situation
I fully understand that my original
Planning Commission was granted on the
two conditions I am looking to vary
thank you however after four years of
trading respecting my local neighborhood
and provide them with a service I
thought RDC can relax or adapt these
conditions in order to satisfy all
parties involved protect occupiers of
neighboring Residential Properties and
private amenity areas so they can
continue to be reasonably enjoyed
in conclusion with all these factors in
place this planning application should
comply to policy dm33 of RDC local
development framework management plan I
would like like to take this opportunity
to thank all members of the board thank
you very much
we have um
councilor Hawaii
as a member and then councilories it was
because you called it in should
counselor East Coast first as he called
it
while it says the high but if you would
like Council I'm happy for Council reps
go first
no no wall councilor was available at
that point and that's why councilory's
called it in I think I should go first
thank you counselor AIDS
to councilor high and thank you chairman
um yes I was going to explain the reason
being why it was myself who called it in
rather than a ward counselor and um uh
this my the calling was done with the
approval of the ward councilors they
just didn't have time to actually bring
it in so hopefully members will
understand that
um in conversation with the applicant
one of the things that was fairly
obvious is that contrary to what we had
on the previous application that we were
considering this guy has done everything
he can to try and conform to everything
that he's been told to do so I think
that there is a little bit of weight
that we need to actually take into
consideration on that and that if we do
propose any condition further conditions
that go on this which I will get on to
that I have every expectation that this
gentleman will conform
the reason for the application has been
because the gentleman is very socially
aware and is trying to help a particular
person
who has an interest in doing
hairdressing and has some anxiety issues
and all that sort of side of things that
aside what we are looking at here is a
young person who's looking to do
training
and that that would be a um in the form
of an apprenticeship as the applicant
has explained so what I would suggest
that we consider
um is the fact that we put a condition
on there that the the allowance for uh
this to be approved uh be limited to the
duration of the apprenticeship so as
there is no chance then of this the the
business taking this particular
application further to develop the the
business uh on for I understand that
there has been a conversation with the
officers on this and the officers are
minded that this could be an acceptable
condition for uh the um for this
particular application
thank you
I'd perhaps like to leave it to Council
of word to speak before I actually make
a proposal thank you
thank you chairman I must stop banging
the mic
um
I support
the application
I think
the applicant has been a very a model
in regards to adhering to his planning
conditions this is really a planning
condition for an apprentice
to help and assist there will be no
additional
customers beyond the two hours that will
allow him to do some more the The
Apprentice won't be
doing the work of a hairdresser between
the work of an apprentice which will be
tidying up shadowing and that's fully
explained in the report
I understand
why um cancer Eaves are suggested
that condition
however the this application does
mention this is only for an apprentice
anyway
and I so it can't expand Beyond an
apprentice
so I I think although it it sounds quite
good to add that condition in
I think
with just looking at this now that we
can I would propose that we
um
approve
the application is made by the applicant
right could you uh
I'll second that chairman thank you I'd
like to speak to the motion as well
please thank you
okay
okay thank you chairman thank you
um yeah I would like to support this um
application and councilor hoy's motion I
see
there's no reference in the report to
economic development that I could see
and I would consider holbridge a low
growth area and I think that promoting
economic growth in whole bridge is
important I don't think we should
omit that and what it can bring to the
Village
and future opportunities so I would like
to support that from listening to
um the applicant I think that the
applicant
the issues he's raised
um in terms of noise
um I I get that and maybe his neighbor
with noise but
as he said children playing in the
garden I don't really think there's
gonna be a lot of difference in the
noise at all with just working in a very
very small Salon in the back Garden
and I think from what I hear
seems like he's quite reasonable about
um keeping to his existing conditions so
I will be supporting it thank you thank
you councilman beautiful members we have
a motion on the table secondly
I do apologize I was looking at anything
like that so who is going to speak first
councilor Constable don't argue again on
this side please
um I'd just like to speak to the motion
in the sense that
um officers stroke strengths sorry I
can't see your name properly from there
brought up the fact that when someone
starts in an apprentice and I can speak
from personal experience having leaving
school at nearly 16 and serve in a three
or four years Apprentice that what tends
to happen is over a period of time
you're trained to such a level where you
are enabling the business to grow in the
sense of you're then putting on tints
you're doing other jobs other than just
um passing up and washing hair and
personally I'm all for
cottage industries starting in garages
at home I think it's great for the
economy it's great for us locally so I'm
fully supportive of that but I do feel
that counselor Eaves does have a very
valid point that once an apprentice gets
to a certain level that you can then
increase the footfall of your business
you can take on more clients so this
business will evolve the point that
officer strengths is making is that at
some point a decision will have to be
made with that Apprentice whether
they've reached a certain level and
qualified that they have to be dismissed
or you you grow the business from within
which would create a larger footfall or
you seek preference premises without
personally I have no objection to which
way it goes but I do think it has to be
considered that you cannot exclude the
fact that taking on a person will not
create more footfall in terms of clients
to that business so from that reason I
do think that cancer leaves condition
that once they've reached full training
that there needs to be some sort of
condition that they either go on to
another Salon externally or the
businesses
[Music]
um
extended to a shop outside
thank you chairman I'd take the
opportunity to come in on one or two of
the points um
we have to be careful we're going back
to the the two tasks that are before us
one is to revisit condition two which is
just personal to the applicant who
you've heard tonight okay now my
Approach listening to the debate would
be was you just need to adapt that
condition which we can do to include The
Apprentice or the trainee however we
describe it there's two ways of doing
that
there is naming them and you could leave
that with officers to incorporate the
name into the consent so that at such
time as she outgrows the post then and
moves on that would be the end of that
but from a planning point of view
it's you're also agreeing the idea that
the activity could accommodate an
apprentice
so
what I would be interested when you come
to the vote is are you saying just this
specific person with her needs
identified that have been expressed in
the application
and that can go one way with the
condition
or whether you're agreeing the
capability of the use to accommodate an
apprentice at any time which is far more
looser so that as one person moved on
another one could pick up on the
opportunities that you're you're
debating so I would like clarification
when the moment comes as to exactly what
you're agreeing but also if it's not out
of term members we've also got a
condition before us about the late hours
perhaps there's going to be a debate and
a movement on that but there's there's
the two conditions not just the one
about The Apprentice if I made that
clear
you're actually doing the apprenticeship
you're agreeing to and the two late
nights
I can hear you but don't let them is it
turned up yet yes
yes thank you very much and to be
absolutely clear the my motion was for
an apprentice it wasn't a named
Apprentice it could be any apprentice
and just for expiration there is only
one chair there if they wanted to get
more than one chair that would have to
go through planning again yeah so it was
quickly there'll still only be one chair
so they're still restricted in what they
can do so if they wanted to discharge
the conditions they've got they've got
to come back to this committee thank you
councilor constable
yes um whilst I'm in favor of taking our
apprenticeships most apprenticeships
have a a term in my day it was four or
five years I think now it's between two
and three years whilst I'm in favor of a
business being aired to train people I
am against the extra extended hours
therefore the motion as it is I can't
support unless the motion uh took out
the extended hours
right members I'm gonna first of all the
motion we have
is that we've got
sorry I didn't see you
if I could just speak to the motion
there please
I think the uh the applicant actually
did Cover the issue of the extra hours
quite comprehensively
in that to say that there would be
additional traffic noise
and general
um
movement
uh in that particular area in that
particular Road I think it's a very very
difficult one to actually justify it
that as refusal because it is a busy
road and it is a bus route and there are
there is a lot of traffic that goes past
those particular houses so I'm a little
bit mystified as to why the neighbor has
actually uh put that in as a um an issue
because it doesn't seem to really add up
so for the applicant then to request
additional hours which were originally
refused on this basis I do find that
rather
strange that we would hold to that so I
would support this motion as it stands
thank you very much thank you I'm the
last person I'm going to speak on this
is councilor Williams please and then we
will
oh sorry council Mrs Mason then that is
it then we'll go to the vote thank you
Council Williams
yeah thank you chairman I I assume that
the should this
applicant dispose of these premises that
permission would remain for somebody
else that purchased that or does it die
with the sale of that
premises
chairman thank you um no the the
condition at the moment is for the
applicant yeah so it stays with him if
he was to move on to another home that
the commit the consent would die
okay so it's personal what members are
looking at is whether adapting that
personal condition to take then an
apprentice
right thank you uh Council this is Mason
uh thank you chair
um I would like to ask that we take the
motion if counselor um I would agree in
the two parts because I think they are
quite distinct one is that the extended
hours of uh two hours on two nights a
week which I can't really see for
everything I've heard any concern about
I think it's utterly reasonable in that
location
but the reason for having an apprentice
is in the report and it's because of the
particular circumstances of that
particular person so I would like to see
the
um if the committee is so decided to
agree to The Apprentice but I would like
to see that person named by in the
officers uh obviously not in public
um so so and it'd be specific to that
one person because otherwise I think we
we have a danger of
the business escalating I know it's not
the intention but having heard what
other members said I think that's a
concern so I would like if counselor is
so minded to put the
um
the request in two parts so that we can
deal with them separately because I
would not like to vote the refusal when
I agree with half of it okay thank you I
don't actually agree with them on my
personal point that we need it no the
person named but Council of Hoy are you
agreeable to have it in two parts or do
you want it as per whole is this your
motion and then I would rather it went
through as it is I understand councilor
Mason's Mrs Mason's point however I
think in this circumstance we've been
told the reason why this person has been
taken on and certain mental health
issues however we name them the name
could be out yeah I don't like the idea
of that and and we have to be mindful
that this is being reported by members
of the public
councilman Newport you still want to
Second emotion and you're happy with it
thank you very much members the motion
is that we approve this application can
I have a show of hands for approval
please
okay
against members
absent your members one
abstentions members
one
two twosa
are you I've signed councilor Gladstone
yeah right thank you I just didn't
right so that's carried members nine
four one against two abstentions thank
you very much
right now we go on to
right I've got all my papers together
because I've shuffled them around
we're going on to London Road Southern
London Road before that I'm going to
read a statement
before I continue with item sevens uh in
Brackets four members I've seen a
Facebook page originating from Dual
weight stating that she had heard
councilor Ian Ward portfolio for
strategic planning and assets
had been lobbying World members World
councilors rather for their support on
this planning application
this is concerning and worrying
allegation and may require further
investigation however my primary issue
this evening is to ensure that this
committee's openness transparency and
regularity compliance can I please ask
any member of this committee to declare
now if they have been lobbied by Council
award
no one's indicated and the next
statement was if I have then they are
permitted to take part in the debate but
not vote on this application thank you
so the application we're going to now is
items for in Brackets it says seven
London Hill Rayleigh 22 stroke zero one
zero zero three full
and I don't think we've got any public
yes we have
yeah who is going to do it Mike again
you're on the stage again thank you Mike
um this application you can see on the
screen outlined heavy there at the site
of seven London Hill curves around at
the top of Rayleigh High Street
Bellingham Lane which we'll talk a lot
about tonight running alongside the Mill
Hall
um just out of out of shot
if we could see the Conservation Area
map please
the site is within the Rayleigh
conservation era on the edge
it'll help if if you give me asset you
chance to rotate it please if that's
possible
thank you
that's okay
um
orientate myself now the site
is there see there's a little star for
those with a keen eye but you'll see
it's within the conservation area which
is a special circumstances
where there's greater sensitivity
towards planning controls
the Bellingham Lane that we were looking
at thank you is curved in alignment we
understand historically to do with
running in parallel with former defenses
to the castle so there's a historic
alignment to Bellingham Lane
and if we can see the first of the the
photos we have please
uh hopefully they're there
we go you'll see our building that
concerns us tonight is this one here
and hopefully the next shot brings us
closer
thank you that's great yep so we're
looking at the provision of solar panels
on this roof h
it's rear-facing which normally wouldn't
give us a problem but because of the
exposure of this part of the elevation
it sort of dominates the Bellingham Lane
area you will see on this newer building
here there are six panels as part of the
planning consent granted to that flatted
building but officers feel that they're
not so injurious as this proposal
because it's time to time they're partly
screened by surrounding development
they're not as prominent as we will see
on the elevations if we can jump to
those first of all I'm going to show you
the building as it is this is the lower
image the back elevation you'll see it's
a large hip roofed expanse that's as it
is or drawn as it is at the current time
if we could jump to the proposal please
you'll see that the application is
proposing 19 solar panels on this south
facing free slope
now Rayleigh Conservation Area is a
designated Heritage asset this is not a
listed building in actual fact in the
appraisal that you have for the
conservation area the building is of
poor quality
but the issue is not so much the harm to
the building it's the harm to the area
the conservation area the Street Scenes
that we were just looking at and street
views that has a certain quality and as
a planning Authority we have a duty a
responsibility in in the decisions that
we take to preserve and enhance that
Conservation Area so at least keep it as
it is in this case the building is
particularly bad
and make it better
and in a nutshell it's officers view
that actually we're taking a building
that is already poor
and if we were to approve this proposal
we'll be making it look a lot worse with
harm to the Conservation Area
now as part of the process of dealing
with the application
offices and the council as a whole seek
specialist view from the Essex County
council's Place Services members of sing
their comments many times in reports
they offer us the expertise to help us
make the difficult decisions to give us
that extra is this right or is it wrong
put simply and members will see that at
page 7.49 of the officer report that
their advice is that permission should
be refused
members would see that you have to
balance the harm because this is what
they call less than substantial harm
it's still a harm to the green to the
Conservation Area
that can be balanced against any public
benefit
now in this case you'll see from the
report that's before you that the solar
panels are considered by both the
offices and specialist advisors
to be out of keeping given their overly
modern shiny uh exterior and the sharp
contrast to the surrounding historic
context
the despite the building being poor
quality in conservation terms the
provision would make the appearance of
the building worse as I've said earlier
already worsening and what is a negative
building
now officers do not consider that the
public benefits set out in the report
outweigh this harm the applicant states
that the proposal represents the latter
stages of a program of work to make the
building more thermally efficient
already they have been improvements in
insulation air tightness and the
replacement of old heaters and if
installed the solar panels would be
accompanied by battery storage so that
when the club is closed it could
continue to store generated power
officer's view is however that despite
being Slimline design and reversible
which means they can be taken off given
the life expectancy of these panels is
usually several years before they need
replacing the duration that they would
be present would be harmful to the
conservation area we're not talking of
something like a caravan temporarily
where somebody rebuilds their subsiding
house or something that's their months
these would be there several years
whatever the life expectancy of these
are
so that harm would be for the duration
of that time and given the limited scale
of the panels proposed we can't help but
feel that this is of private benefit not
public benefit there is a a wider public
for benefit that if everybody including
this applicant make the effort to
generate Renewable Power that is for the
benefit of us all but officers feel that
concern doesn't outweigh the specific
harm to the green belt that our
specialist advisors and ourselves see
before you so there are public benefits
there's footfall to people coming to the
club and keeping that open there is the
activity that those people might spend
in the local shops and services keeping
that activity
but we haven't seen anything in the
application particulars that demonstrate
any viability or assuredness that you
could rely on I think as members to say
that the harm of those panels is
outweighed by those such as they are
public benefits
so the recommendation chairman is
refusal for the reason that's set out in
the report
thank you Mike we have one speaker
public speaker is Mr John Dyke
oh good evening you're already up you've
got five minutes and as you know you
have I'll let you know when there's four
minutes is gone
good evening chairman good evening
members your consideration should be
first addressing the legal requirement
to give special attention to the desired
ability of preserving or enhancing the
character or appealance of the
Conservation Area
preservation means not causing harm so
if you think that this isn't causing
harm it's in accord with the legal Duty
secondly you should have regard to the
relevant policies of the development
plan and other material considerations
and the nppf is obviously a weighty
consideration both it and the
development plan must be read as a whole
and subject to the legal Duty the
decision should be made in accordance
with the development plan and less
material considerations indicate
otherwise
the approach that the officer report
identifies two issues as Mr strengths
has just pointed out
the impact of the proposal and the
character and appearance or significance
Heritage value of the conservation area
and secondly the weight to be given to
the accepted accepted in the report
public benefit of this renewable energy
proposal
7.94 megawatt hours per annum a saving
of 1.85 tons of CO2 emissions
however and not not all relevant
policies of the development plan have
been mentioned in the report actually
not all modern policies of the nppf have
been mentioned in the report or by Place
services and place Services have put
forward a rather brief consultation
response
the applicant's Heritage consultant
considers that the impact of The
Proposal is not harmful this follows
from a structured assessment of the club
building in its context that's to say in
its false setting applying historic
England guidance if members think that
it is if if members think that that is
right there is no need to go on and
balance impact against benefit the
effect on character and appearance of
the area would be neutral it would be
preserved and planning permission can be
properly granted
your development plan at cp2 provides
for regard to be had to the conservation
area appraisal 2007. Mr strengths
referred to that but not very fully this
should be considered when you
considering proposals it's referred to
in the report the club building is
categorized as having a negative effect
on character but also the view North
East along Bellingham Lane is also
classed as negative conservation areas
do vary in their character across their
areas
the nature of a club building is
recognized by Place Services as negative
in the report but nevertheless it's
asserted that harm will result from the
installation references made to the
incongruous that's to say out of place
panels which would appear overly modern
and of a shiny material in sharp
contrast to the historic context
consider the photograph at 748 of your
report it's the only photograph in the
report and it was put up on the screen
that's looking Northeast you're very
familiar with it it's just outside this
Hall this is the background area of the
High Street this particular area of the
conservation area really has no Heritage
value
no proper assessment is made by Place
services or in the report of number
22-24 with its expansive glass shiny
front modernist form and ground floor
car parking
the solar panels on its roof are
mentioned you may feel that they can be
seen but they're not prominent due to
their slim profile and color in this
context it's difficult to see how harm
could arise from this proposal the
panels will be visible but will they
really be out of place they will match
the club roof cladding in color and
they'll be of slim profile which was of
course accepted by Mr strengths
even if harm does arise it is at the
lowest level less than substantial harm
as assessed by police services and as
accepted in the report
any lower level harm is surely
outweighed by the public benefit
see the nppf at 2002. now sorry at 202
paragraph 202 where a development
proposal will lead to less than
substantial harm to the significance I.E
Heritage value of Conservation Area this
harm should be weighed against the
public benefits of The Proposal note the
support for renewable energy in your own
development planner dnv7 and then note
the nppf at 158 under the chapter title
meeting the challenge of climate change
and it says authorities should recognize
that even small-scale projects provide a
valuable contribution to cutting
greenhouse gas emissions and approve the
application of its impact to acceptable
I say these impacts are acceptable and
members for these reasons I suggest it
would be entirely reasonable for the
committee to Grant planning permission
thank you very much
any visiting members would like to speak
on this
no indication I have councilor Foster
would like to speak on this other
council Mrs Mason
thank you chairman
rdc's website States not all solar
panels in the conservation area required
planning permission if the solar panels
do not front to Highway planning
permission would not be required
the West Wall of the building fronts
Bellingham Lane the north wall front
London Hills Church Street
the South Wall does not front a highway
so I don't believe that the proposal for
these south facing solar panels even
needs planning permission
however since we're here some context
the RDC website talks about business
support with a strong message about
backing business and in the recent
budget meeting the financial paper
stated Town centers are dying and need
all the help they can get
now to the site proposal in the report
before this evening
in paragraph one it states it's within
close proximity of grade 2 listed
building the windmill correct as the
crow flies of course however
Katie could have picture one please
this shows the view of the West Wall of
the club face in Bellingham Lane taken
from a gap between two houses opposite
the club this is the only place
from which the club might be visible
from the direction of the mill but it's
not actually visible from the ground
level at the Mill
even if it were the proposed panels
would not be visible facing south
I could have pictured too please Katie
this picture is from the rear path of
Holy Trinity Church looking across to
the north elevation of the club
therefore no panels on the south facing
roof would be visible
picture three please go to
this picture is from the front door of
the Rayleigh Church on London Hill
mentioned in the report
a conservative Club is not even visible
the club is also not visible from
Rayleigh mount
in paragraph three the statement that
the solar panels would front the highway
is incorrect they will be at right
angles to the highway as we have seen
from that first picture
I admit the highway does curve later on
moving on to the impact on the
conservation area and public benefits
paragraph 23 States it's acknowledged
that the existing building is a negative
contributor
that's an opinion
of Essex Place services and I don't
think it's being tested
paragraph 21 states Bellingham Lane
follows the line of the former Bailey
dick outer Bailey ditch the application
does not affect the line of Bellingham
Lane so why is it material
therefore that comment isn't relevant
Katie could we have picture four please
I'd like to give members a moment to
look at that picture
paragraph 22 describes the application
as an incongruous feature of the street
Swing Street Scene sorry
in paragraph 33 it's dismissive has been
harmful to the street scene of
Bellingham Lane and being in a prominent
position and setting a precedent
a precedent has already been set at
22-24 Bellingham Lane where there are
already solar panels with the same sound
for facing aspect as the proposed panels
um you don't can't really see them very
well in this picture but if you take the
picture from further up Bellingham Lane
as you saw earlier the solar panels on
22-24 are visible
look more carefully at the street scene
there's a steel chimney or vent
somewhere up there right in the middle
perhaps I should point to them
spare with me a second while I touch my
technology
up there thank you whoever did that was
that thank you right
um Foster can you turn yours off please
right
okay
um so there's a
stainless steel chimney or vent there's
air conditioning units various points
all along there some you can face you
can see could you point to them for me
there and further down to the right just
the right of that right lump of a
building
that wonderful picture of the street
scene
and further up as well
uh there's also the rear of the Rayleigh
cars the industrial unit
there's a plethora of rubbish skips
along the road there there's a
businessman parked every day there
uh how on Earth can putting solar panels
on the top of the conservatory Club
could you point to the conservatory Club
from their police gating
that little blob in the distance
so how on Earth
putting panels on this roof be judged to
be harmful to the street scene
in paragraph 33 the report effectively
dismisses the application saying the
applicant has not presented within the
application a benefit to the public at
large as required by the mppf and mppg
but rather a limited reduction in CO2
and a clear private benefit in the
reduction of energy costs the 18
paragraph 26 quoting nppg it states
however benefits do not always have to
be visible or accessible to the public
in order to be genuine public benefits
worryingly given the RDC commitment to
business in paragraph 31 it states the
applicant fails for evidence that the
business would cease if it fails to get
approval I'm unaware that an application
for this what I would call a
climate-friendly change requires
avoidance of failure of business as a
precondition of planning approval
in paragraph 37 it dismissively
describes a relatively small
contribution towards mitigating the
effects of climate change
yet in paragraph 41 it reports a
proposal to place the panels on the
western end of the roof which would
significantly reduce the the power
generated so for being conclusion
yes I will the conclusion the proposed
refusal of this application is based on
very weak arguments overstated negative
impact on the conservation area
incorrect information against against an
environmentally friendly proposal
anti-business and I said at the start
according to our DC website not all
solar panels in the conservation era
required planning permission
given all this I therefore move for
approval of the application
we've got people wanting to speak on
um thank you
thank you chair I shall try and keep
within the time limits
um
I think everyone knows on this committee
at least that I like solar panels indeed
I put a motion to counsel recently
asking for these to be recommended on
all new buildings
so
I was intrigued however when I saw this
application and I saw the reason for the
call-in was in the grounds of public
interest
I've been on the council for 12 years
I've had countless training sessions
most of them quite excellent
I've had questions and answer sessions
with officers on on applications I've
sat through two public inquiries
and we've been told time and time again
that we must judge any applicant
planning application on material
planning concerns
yeah I've never heard
of in the public interest being a
material planning concern so
either I've missed it or it wasn't and
it is
and that's usually our reason for
calling something in a material planning
concern
so
I'd like the officers later on to
clarify if in the public interest is
material planning concern and if so I'd
like it added
to the reasons for refusal because I
support refusal
the home to the Conservation Area
is debatable the screen the Aesthetics
of a street scene are debatable
what isn't debatable is the site of
solar panels I have them on my own house
and I regret it because I though they
are very good and very efficient
I don't like the look of them they are
imposing and unfortunately they spoil
the look of the house which is one of
those things
so
the harm to the conservation area I
think would be greater and I don't think
there would be any public benefit
unfortunately from this so I will be
moving or supporting the officer's
recommendation which I think has been
very well thought out for refusal thank
you
I yes thank you chairman
I I'm
I'm really just saying that I'm going to
be supporting refusal on this the
officers have done a pretty good job
with report I'm I would just like to
point out to members that on page 7.4.9
yes it's County Council Place service is
historic buildings and conservation
advice
um I'll just pick out a few paragraphs
from there which back up what the
officers have said for instance
introducing an incongruous feature would
which would fail to preserve the
character or appearance of radio
Conservation Area
they've said due to the location of the
proposed solar panels these shall
feature prominently so they're saying
they're going to be prominent
the cumulative impact of further
negative additions to the conservation
areas should be avoided so despite the
fact there are there might be some now
I
um
air conditioning vents we shouldn't make
it worse
um
in the second paragraph
the um Club had a get out it says I know
there is a flat roofed extension to the
rear would it be possible to place low
profile solar panels in this location
this would potentially have little
little to no impact as a panel would not
be visible so I think they're they've
been quite helpful there they're trying
to help the conservative Club put panels
in in an appropriate place which would
not be
detrimental to the conservation area I'd
also add I I'm aware you can go up Holy
Trinity tail I'm aware you can go up the
mill and I think those panels would be
prominent from so from both places if
not on the ground so that's just my
reasons for supporting refusal thank you
thank you account slurries
thank you chair
I found myself a little bit um uh more
than just a bit concerned here because
this decision is going to be seen as
being political
uh it's not going to be seen as being
something that is uh taken on Merit
because unfortunately being the
conservative Club is in everyone who is
a conservative member to vote in favor
of this and I'm sure that that's the way
it will go when it comes to the vote I
have that distinct feeling
um Mr dag in his uh Speech to the
committee and I quote him he said that
the building has no Heritage value I
think he's completely missed the point
if we go walk around in the Conservation
Area
the conservation area has plenty of ugly
buildings
but it is a Conservation Area
and that is the whole point of it now
you can actually see clearly that roof
from the road
despite what others have actually said
in the position it is I I do see that
the officers have tried to be helpful
and suggested alternative placement so
that's that's fine
um but I'm surprised that there hasn't
been any consideration of that
um the the thing that I I I think is
most concerning here
is the reputational risk that this
decision will give to the council
because what will the public will see
was will be that if this is approved it
is the conservative Administration who
are not liking what the officers are
doing and therefore turning over for
their own advantage
now whether that's right or not I don't
know that's not for me to judge but that
is how the public are going to view it
and so I do find this rather more
concerning than just the application
and I will be voting in favor of refusal
thank you very much councilories
councilor Newport
thank you very much chairman
um
well how do you follow
follow on from the other members
basically
the officer as as put forward the case
um and not just our own officers but
Essex have put forward the case for
refusal and I cannot find anywhere in
that that I could personally argue with
when we look at Rayleigh and the
conservation area I've seen many many
photos of aerial shots of the
conservation area and I when I look at
them do I see solar panels no I don't
and we must protect
our Conservation Area whether that's
from the ground or from above
this is basically set this would set a
president and we will not be able to
roll back from that
once we say yes to one application
that will just snowball
we will not be sat here debating whether
we're going to allow more solar panels
because we know the argument that will
come before us the inspector will
overrule because this if approved
tonight will set that President and I
don't see the only public interest here
is to refuse this application solar
panels are not appropriate in the
conservation area thank you chairman
before I put it to the vote members I
just will point out on seven points
7.4 point
right I'll do mine first please
7.4.8 there is a picture but 22 24 has
already got solar panels so that has
been president has been stated already
okay so we can't
because any other activation wants them
we already have them in that no that's
what I'm going to say
councilor Newport you said we would set
a precedent if any solar panels were put
on a building which we've got as per the
thing councilor Gadsden
my question is
um
as discussed we have solar panels on the
building and I accepted his new building
so as there is a precedent so are we
saying that if the conservative Club was
demolished and rebuilt that it would be
acceptable to put solar panels on it
and also with with regards to the flat
roof that would not provide sufficient
energy to heat the club and regarding
sort of political football that's going
on
we all declared a non-pecuni interest
I'd also like to State quite clearly
because members of the public here we do
know as conservative members benefit
financially at all from the conservative
club actually it costs us money to
belong so when we're looking at benefits
there is no benefit to us I think you're
also missing the point that we are here
to support businesses it is a business
and with over 500 members who are not in
generally large amount not politically
active do use this club they do find
emotional support by being a member of
this club by meeting and being able to
leave home which a lot of them are
elderly so there is the benefit to the
greater public by having a club as is
any local establishment When you mention
of a commercial outlets in the area this
is a significant benefit in terms of
that and the the extortionate energy
bills that people are facing in business
and this is a business do need the
support of the council to need to enable
them to keep going to benefit the area
um so I I feel that I do understand its
Conservation Area I do understand that
not all conservation areas are pretty
but I do feel the fact that you've
already permitted it on a new building
bright shiny new building there's a shy
brining brine shiny metal chimney thing
up there as well I personally do not
think that the street scene is directly
affected by these panels and I just fail
to understand why we've had a guest
speaker I don't know who the guest
speaker is but he has put counter
proposals to what's been said by
officers and I actually think that maybe
we need time out to look at the
additional information provided by
whoever that gentleman is over there so
that we can have a full understanding
because when informations brought to a
meeting like this and we haven't had
time to research it I'm not quite
understood I understand how a decision
is made when abstracts of reports are
taken Here There and Everywhere and I'd
really like to see either this deferred
so that we can go into it further and
maybe come to a greater understanding
but I've at the moment I feel that it's
only fair to support the the application
to have these panels put on top
with you Sonia we have
it yeah we have we've got to speak to
them for refusal
I was advised that the time spent
putting up photographs
and allowing members to absorb the
photographs would not count towards five
minutes
I believe that I didn't get my
five-minute speaking time and my motion
to approval was within the five minutes
no sorry uh councilor Foss
wrong there
as soon as you put the photographs up
Sonia stop the stop clock so she did
stop so the photo as I was agreed that
as we do always and as did we cancel the
first and we stopped the stop clock you
had the photographs members could see
them and then you went speaking and we
started the stop clock you actually went
to five minutes 34 seconds so we did
actually thank you chairman so we did
actually do it fairly as we did for
councilor McPherson
okay just that for clarity members we've
got emotional
that's missing
so I thought councilor Gaston put in a
motion for deferral
okay I'm sorry sorry then no then she
said no
then she said she would approve it right
okay we've got
Clarity right okay we've got
my recommendation
is for refusal members can I have a show
of hands
there are four refusal
the other coast
well I could do but I won't tonight so
you're not have done unless it's
protocol we don't need our members to
stay until for a recorded vote
I just want to clarify in case anyone
says right
right can you put up your hands for
refusal please
uh yeah but we are no want to know who's
going to refuse it and then we can put
it as a recorded vote right so
nope we're having about
Sonia is having a moment to mark up
things
oh you oh you got one sorry I do
apologize thank you
counselor constable
councilor Crips
four
councilor FD
councilor Eaves
councilor Foster
councilor Mrs Gadsden
counselor hoy
councilor Mrs Mason
councilor Milne
councilor Mrs Shaw
counselor
Newport sorry
councilor Williams
okay
fine okay
five four
so it's five four
six against one extension
so that has been lost so it is
case can I move for deferment thank you
lost the folk for foreign
was for a refusal yes I'm done and we
voted and you lost we thought that it's
like any application we've lost it was
the recommendation by officers was a
refusal we vote against it members have
gone against the recommendation of the
officers and we've voted for so the
recommendation from the officers has
been lost we now go on to the next one
no it's gone we've lost we've done it
finished
and I'm going now going to have a five
minute break because I've just been
asked for one
okay so it's quarter past I'm gonna
I'm going by that clock over there it's
quarter past even though it doesn't say
20 past by this clock in the room can be
please come back
you've got to give them an opportunity
okay yeah you can't I'm just trying to
remember
and also maybe it might be playing it
might be different because because
normally if
the other
have a council meetings if you lose
because we was voted for the officer's
recommendations
planning you planning you cannot just
finish that you cannot just
about the opportunity drop
s the jet appropic conditions if it
would be challenging position
and also because because
okay
can you set the mic up please
members can we sit down please
so basically
right members I've just been advised I
took the decision too soon so I do
apologize so now we've
voted that
we will not refuse this so have we
another motion on the table
yes you did what was your can I have
your motion again please Mrs Mason
yes certainly I'm moving for deferment
on the grounds of the fact that we need
more information
the the
um
public perception and the information
that the speaker gave us which I think
councilor gadstone did point out that it
would be helpful to have that in the
report expanded to cover that but I'm
moving for deferment and I also think it
would be good for this Council to defer
it so that uh reputation wise
Newport thank you
members can I have a vote on this motion
for deferral please
in favor of a deferral of this
application
members against
deferment can we please have a vote
anyone on Stein
so we have four
four deferral
five against deferral
sorry five five so five
four deferral
five against deferral two of sanctions
and I have the casting vote and I'm
voting against deferral
there's no need to be sarcastic
right we have a now have an emotional
table for
approval of this application have your
secondary please
the cards right
our officers would like to come in and
it's like who would like to come in
Council
thanks chairman sorry uh we have had
some conditions ahead if counselors
would mind just having a look to see if
whether they would consider these
acceptable
okay so they were just on the screen the
first one is the standard one to do with
time so uh to be to take place within
three years of the date of the
permission uh the second one is also
mostly the standard one listing the
plans but also
um to do with
sorry I had put in about the spec of it
but it seems to have disappeared from
the wording but um so it should read the
development hit by committee should be
carried out in complete accordance with
the specification as listed in the
application
um and the following approved plans
I can't just type that in if it helps
okay so members with these additional
conditions
we now have a motion on the table for to
approve this application and we have a
they're out there
yes
you would like another recorder that's
not a problem
just gets Sonia to sort the paperwork
out
do we have to vote on the conditions
conditions as I said okay thank you
oh yeah sorry
thank you
okay
councilor constable
you're voting for approval of the
application subject to the conditions as
outlined by the officer
thank you councilor Crips
Council of FD
councilor Eaves
councilor Foster
councilor Gadsden
councilor hoy
councilor Mrs Mason
yeah
councilor Milne
councilor Newport
councilor Mrs Shaw
councilor Williams
oh sorry right members there's six four
five against and one extension so this
has been now being carried and the
refusal has been approved thank you
[Music]
oh sorry
sorry sorry
debating
I'm not feeling great you're right just
to stop the meeting so you no no help I
I'll just go right okay thank you very
much
wish you well
members
we now will go back to agenda item seven
stroke 2 22 stroke zero one one six
eight full site of 22 and 24 South End
Road Hockley
Casey Foster
coyote Fowler I'm getting tired we'll
present the officer's report I do
apologize
thank you chairman sorry I'm just
checking I've got all the plans in order
can you hear me can I just declare a
non-precluded interest as a ward
counselor
yep and thank you
yes Casey
thank you chairman
so the application site is outlined in
red and can be seen here on the aerial
photograph on the screen so hopefully
that's clear
the site is located to the east of
Savannah Road roundabout which can be
seen on the left hand side of the screen
um and is on the corner of Great Eastern
Road which runs northwards here
there are some notable buildings along
South End Road such as the library which
is located here and the fire station
building just located north of that
the site front South End Road and also
Great Eastern Road and given its Corner
plot location it has a prominent site
within the street scenes of Southend
Road and Great Eastern Road
plan information is sought for the
demolition of the existing Bungalows on
site and the construction of three
Terrace dwellings the dwellings would
have pitched roofs with two-story bay
window features to the front elevation
the rear elevations would be finished
with single-story ground floor
projections and a Gable end dormer-like
feature to the roof space
just seeing this one out so we can see
all three dwellings would face onto
South End roads an area of substantial
Landscaping has been included along the
western flank boundary and to the
frontage of plot C hopefully that should
be visible just along here and then plot
C is this plot
plot ANC would utilize existing
vehicular accesses off of South End Road
and Great Eastern Road and the vehicular
access to plot B would be the only
formation of a new axis
the proposed development has been
amended following refusal of a previous
scheme for three dwellings so the plans
on the top show the previous scheme
which was refused and the block plan
just in this corner and the bottom is
what's proposed now and the block plan
for that
the issues raised related to the urban
Green Building line and design and the
Compact and clutter development that
would result
the proposal has been amended by
creating a Terrace of three dwellings
that is set back from the building line
of Great Eastern Road and follows the
plot widths which are characteristic of
this area
the design has also been simplified so
that the detailing complements rather
than clutter's elevations
additional soft Landscaping has been
introduced along the western flank in
light of the amendment to create a row
of terraces overall officers have
considered the proposal to overcome the
previous grants of refusal
members may be familiar with the
application site as there have been a
number of applications which have come
before them previously in particular are
the two flattered schemes which can be
seen on the screen
both applications were refused and
dismissed by the planning inspector at
appeal the left hand scheme was
initially dismissed due to its dominant
appearance and sense of overdevelopment
and lack of adequate parking then the
inspector particularly made note of the
scale of the building in terms of the
length of the elevations and its height
following the dismissal the right hand
scheme was submitted and refused the
inspectorate proceeded to dismiss the
appeal due to harm to the character of
the area inadequate parking provision
insufficient space standards and a lack
of mechanism to secure the Rams payment
the inspector noted within their
decision that they considered the
reduced higher acceptable but that the
elevations were still of significant
length and our odds with the scale and
proportions of the buildings within the
street scene
here we can see the comparisons between
the appeal schemes and the proposed
development so the top scheme is the
first refused application the middles is
the second and then the bottom one is
what is proposed now
whilst the development can be considered
comparatively in terms of its
architectural scale style and height to
the first appeal it was not the height
alone that the appeal was dismissed for
but rather combined with the scale of
this development
whatever
this shows this slide shows a comparison
of the side elevations is evident the
extent of elevation which has been
reduced the top screen being the top
drawing being the first appeal and the
bottom one being prepared was proposed
now
the inspector's decision focused on the
cumulative impact of the height and
length of elevations which resulted in
the over development
the proposed development although a
similar height to the appeal schemes
would have a significantly less depth
and if I just show the plot plans here
as well you can see that the extent of
built form has been reduced and just to
for spur the clarification there is a
dotted line which goes up here and so
although from here it looks as though
the development only
went somewhere along great Eastern Road
it actually extended back to here and
this was a first and second floor
element so still projected quite deeply
into that plot
although the height of the proposed
dwellings would be marginally greater
than those of the terrorist dwellings
adjacent they have been considered to be
in keeping with the character and
appearance of the area looking at the
street scene of South End Road we can
see that it is incredibly mixed there is
no set building typology or Ridgeline
instead each dwelling varies greatly
plot to plot the photon screen shows a
dramatic change in midline between
two-story dwellings and a bungalow in
the background and even the two-story
dwellings in the foreground so we have
here a bungalow
and then next to it we have two-story
dwellings but then again two-story
dwelling which is greater in height and
then the same between this Bungalow
there's two sort of dwelling and then
the two-story dwelling here compared to
the terrorist property here and the
detached two story here
um and this is even evident between the
existing application site and the
Terrace property next door where there
is a dramatic change in Ridge height
it's also seen to the east of the
application site where uh if you're
traveling towards hawkwell
whilst the development would certainly
take on a modern appearance it is not
considered that this would be out of
keeping with the character of Hockley
along that South End Road and up to Spa
Road around about a variation of
architectural Stars can be seen ranging
from the locally listed Spa part
building to spa place in the background
and so you can see Spa Pub here and then
just in the background although we're
not very clear spa place
on the southern side side of Southend
Road a flatter schemes built in the
neo-georgian architectural style but
adjacent to some examples of modernist
architecture architecture and that can
be seen on the left hand side of the
screen here
the variation of architectural Styles is
therefore evident along Southend Road
even along great Eastern Road the
materials used in The Finisher
properties varies and creates a
different appearance between the
dwellings
given the greatly differing building
typology and Architectural styles of
Southland Road there is not considered
to be a character in this area in this
sense that the development must follow
there is character of the local area in
terms of plot widths building lines and
urban grain which can be considered as
size and configuration of plots
however the revised proposal has been
considered in keeping with each of these
characteristics in addition The Proposal
would not be considered to have an
impact upon adjoining residents that
would be unreasonable for the built-up
context of the application site although
it was mentioned within the officer
report that the trees along the northern
boundary so they can just be seen to the
top of the screen here
should be retained and we have received
a comment from a neighbor requesting
that the trains are no longer required
to be retained the addendum is spoken to
this and amended the landscape and
condition so as to not require the trees
to be retained The Proposal would be
utilize two existing access points and
proposes the creation of a third from
South End Road the highway Authority
have not objected to this vehicular
access each dwelling would be capable of
accommodating two or street car parking
spaces measuring to the apoa parking
standards the proposed development would
also be compliant with the council's
requirement of garden sizes refuse
storage space standards and habitat
mitigation the application is
recommended for approval chairman
subject to the conditions set out in the
report and the amendment to condition
for as outlined in the addendum thank
you thank you very much Katie we have
one public speaker at the applicant and
it's Mr Bashar Ali
thank you very much you've got a fight
you've seen it out it's gone all evening
it's five minutes I'll let you know when
you've been done before thank you Sharon
um
see ya so first of all we're we're
locally based anyway we have we are
um we're sort of independent contractors
and we have families of our own and we
understand the difficulties families
have in finding accommodation having
family housing with sufficient space and
so we've taken on board a lot of the
comments that have been made and we've
looked at the history of the refusals in
terms of uh the flats that were
originally designed and put forward
they've all been refused and we've taken
that on board and we've worked very
closely with the planners to try and
come up with a scheme that is very
sensitive to all the objections that
have been made and we've come up with a
scheme I believe that is
taken on board all those objections
particularly coming up with a
traditional design
and we've worked carefully and
extensively with the planners throughout
in in resulting in this scheme
the traditional scale houses are similar
to many others in the area and exactly
as number 20 on the opposite side of the
junction and I think one of the key
concerns was the fact that we were going
or referred to a third floor but that is
no different to an individual having a
loft conversion so we don't see what
what that what problem that actually
causes and with with the Architects
we've confirmed that obviously there is
no difference in terms of the the
Viewpoint from the second floor to the
third floor there is no difference so
having that third floor is no different
to someone having a loft conversion so I
don't quite understand why there's such
an objection to that
um we've also made sure that there's
well proportioned fenestrations that
respect the traditional orientation of
the houses on Southern roads the houses
also respect the distances to the
boundaries and neighboring properties
exactly as number 20 on the opposite
side of the junction
furthermore the houses are positioned
four meters further from the rear
building than the existing Bungalows
thus increasing the garden depth and
separation from number one great the
more grace and Road
um we've also included large landscape
areas to the front the side and the re
and the rear we've reused the existing
vehicle access the egress to the main
road
and the houses respect and follow the
building line of both roads
so our request is is that the community
members respect the recommendation of
the planning experts and Grant
permission thank you thank you Mr Ali
we've got no visiting members of the
council here now
um so it'll be councilories
order Madam chairman as I've got an
indirect keynary interest I should speak
and leave all right sorry thank you
before I suppose
to do it the evening I'd love to leave
all right
um
yeah thank you for the opportunity this
this application it has a couple of
demerits in my view that I don't like
the third floor I know that there is a
tendency to that
however it is a fast Improvement on the
planning applications we've seen on this
site and the importance of this site is
that as you come over the hill hawkwell
hill from the
right heart
you see this building before you see
anything else it is the entrance to
Hockley so it is very dominant my only
concern with this and it's not a real
concern I I do think it's a vast
Improvement is I've seen the planting
scheme looks lovely on paper and I know
the offices have put condition in and I
know that they want it done in the first
planting season but I do would like to
see that really rigidly adhered to and I
would like to see it very soft and and
quite tall because of the prominence of
the um location but that's all I've got
to say on this and I will depart thank
you would you like uh the opposite to
come back on that uh Council mate Mrs
Mason before you leave no I'm quite
happy that it's in in the report I just
wanted to
reinforce the importance of that
normally I wouldn't because the planting
scheme is done but because of the
location it is more important than it
would ordinary be so and I'm hoping if a
developer is here hopefully he's aware
of it and uh we'll have it in nice and
early thank you thank you you are coming
back for the last application
thank you very much councilman
you could go you can go home if you
would like to
councilories you know you're more than
welcome to come back we'll give you a
call
thank you
um I agree with councilor Mason that
this is a big Improvement on what we've
seen before however I do have a number
of concerns uh with this particular
application the applicant has said about
the third floor being regarded more as a
loft conversion when the first
application was made the appeal was held
because of the third floor when the
second application came in that wasn't
actually considered part of it but if
you look at the application that came in
on the second time round the bonnets
were tiny and the overlooking was not
there
now what we have on this application is
some very large picture windows in the
back so far from being equivalent to a
loft conversion this is a genuine third
floor also the ridge height is higher
than adjacent buildings now to claim
that the the area would actually be
um
mirroring other buildings in the area
they've got three floors we've been
through this before this particular plot
is not regarded and that was held up on
appeal is not regarded as regarded as
being the center of Hockley where there
are multiple story dwellings so that
cannot be held as a reason for that I do
have concerns over the parking for the
plot that's on the corner the two spots
that are at the back there I know in the
report that they said that they were
rather small
but they also come out right adjacent to
a bus stop
and to say that that is a safe exit
there when it's right next to a bus stop
I think is uh somewhat of a mistake
the overlooking uh to um
the
gardens in the Great Eastern Road is
considerable and it is very very obvious
if the
um the committee are minded to actually
agree this item then I would suggest
that the windows that are out the back
are given a condition of having limiters
on their opening and having Frosty
windows in them frosted glass in them
bin storage I'd be very interested to
see where the officers reckon that bin
storage would actually be in particular
for the um the house that's actually in
the middle of the Terrace because I
don't see anything
for that I understand that with the
other ones they could take them around
the back but I'm not sure where I'm
seeing it for the uh for the middle one
the um
if you look at the aspect of Great
Eastern Road and the impact that this
actually has going from a bungalow to a
three-story building the impact on the
street scene in Great Eastern Road is
quite significant and I think that
should have been taken into
consideration I will be voting against
approval on this thank you
I think it's my fault for having the
plans as they were I believe this strip
of hard standing at the top of the car
parking would serve the bins for this
Central property so that they would be
able to drag them out to the street
there
no I've got um I've got a few I've
councilor Gadsden
uh being a wall cancer yeah
um I'd actually like to support most of
what councilor Eve says and I'm
particularly concerned that five bedroom
properties the amount of parking or car
ownership
would seldom B2 cars those roads do not
lend themselves to off street parking
and at the moment I really do not feel I
can support this application in its
present form
councilor FD
thank you chair
um
it's difficult one I don't have support
or not support this one but I do have a
problem with the ridge line and the
chimneys why are ridgelines now to the
top of the chimneys next door it
it frustrates me that because it's not
in line with the rich it's in line with
the chimney I listened to the rest of
the arguments that's my main problem
with this
is there any other members that Nick
would like to speak on this please
constable
yes um
I don't have a problem with the
development I do have a problem with the
height development uh being the three
story if it was a two-story development
um I would be more in favor of it but
it's not it's too big and it's out of
character with the area and with five
bedrooms if they've got three or four
children the car parking at a later date
is going to become a nightmare and that
is part of a bus route on both roads so
in its present condition I can't support
it either
I would like to propose that we refuse
the application on the grounds that it
is overhyped
um and this and on the third story and
the lack of parking for five property
building I'll be your second or please
right members we've got a motion on the
table poor refusal of this application
so officers would like to come back
sorry I do apologize sorry thank you
chairman
um I would just have concern regarding
the refusal for parking uh just because
for five bedroom properties we are
required to have a have two off-street
parking standards by of parking spaces
by our standards that we've adopted so
pushing for any more is not in our
policy and we don't have that backing
um so and I do appreciate that we have
had appeals on this site previously
relating to parking but with this scheme
we have got adequate parking which meet
those standards they're not the minimum
Dimensions they are the preferred base
sizes
um so I I would just be concerned to
defend that point where it is compliant
with our policy in that regard
and have the rest of for your refusal
I'm happy to go along with the officer's
recommendation on parking
this time thank you very much
sorry um I did prepare a reason for a
fuse though I think probably based on
the discussion I'll just amend it
slightly uh to what it was but it will
read something along the lines of uh the
proposed development by virtue of its
height I would take out scaling density
as the discussion hasn't surrounded that
uh so like that would result in
overdevelopment of the application site
to the detriment of the character and
appearance of the area The Proposal
would be contrary to policy dm1 and dm3
of the development management plan and
the mppf
but I propose that we include in there
after the proposed proposed development
by virtue of its height and inclusion of
the third floor
oh you're right with that Katie oh good
grief
right members we've got a motion on the
table for a refusal of this application
and it's been seconded can I have a show
of hands
four refusal
right can I have
or vote for this application again
against against refusals
to
any abstentions members
so
this members is refused there was six
four refusal
two against refusal and two of
extinctions now members is coming up to
so that has been refused members it's
coming up to 10 10 we've got one more
application to go forward
um can I have a show of hands if you
would like you want to carry on with
this committee meeting to get this
application done or we close the meeting
now can I have a show of hands four
carrying on for
oh yeah also we've got to get Christine
back so have a think
oh
yeah
I'm tired
welcome back Mrs Mesa councilor Mrs
Mason right I've just put on to the I
said welcome back it's just I've just
put forward that we've got one more
application and before this microphone
collapse it completely collapses on me
we need to vote that we will hear this
application or do we defer this
application to the next meeting so can I
have a show of hands to carry on this
meeting please
Force carrying it on
it's one application
so anyway like can I have against
we're gonna yeah
yeah sorry
so we're going to do the last
application on the
way no we'll just say we're going to do
it let me finish I was going to do the
last application will be on the next
meeting
all right that's three facts people
would let me finish what I was going to
say thank you ma'am that's right thank
you members I will close this meeting at
bypassed councilor Mason you need to
come back
I would have gone home
you you never know no that's true